franchement vous aviez une vie
formidable cartonnée sur ces news Figaro
des chroniques partout puis vous avez
décidé de vous lancer dans la dans la
politique donc je suis sûr que vous
gagnez beaucoup moins d'argent que
maintenant qu'avant ça c'est sûr si vous
voulez me dire que j'ai fait des
sacrifices c'est sûr mais bon d'accord
comme ça vous avez fait le bon choix
je pense que oui je vais vous dire je si
vous voulez
vous savez je vais vous raconter une
histoire vous oui par exemple
une histoire drôle
je vais vous dire parce que en fait la
question que vous posez c'est pourquoi
vous y êtes allé c'est ça non parce que
je comprends on se dit on se dit
franchement tout vous réussissez
en plus vous étiez un petit peu voilà
vous pouviez donner des des leçons des
dire voilà ça c'est bien ça c'est pas
bien et à un moment on y va
c'est incontestable que j'ai fait des
sacrifices je vous répète mais je vais
vous expliquer par une par une histoire
quelques mois avant cette décision je je
lis une biographie d'un grand historien
journaliste que j'admirais beaucoup vous
savez quand on admire on s'identifie un
peu
qui avait vécu
dans les années d'entre-deux-guerres il
y a un siècle à peu près et qui
s'appelait Jacques Bainville et j'ai
découvert à l'occasion de cette lecture
que cet homme à la fin de sa vie juste
avant sa mort avait dit à son fils qu'il
regrettait en fait de ne jamais avoir
osé franchir le Rubicon avoir osé
rentrer en politique active cette engagé
être resté un observateur un journaliste
un historien et qui vendait énormément
de livres qui avait beaucoup de succès
qui était renommé qui était influent qui
avait une influence même sur les hommes
politiques de l'époque etc et je vous
avoue que ça m'a fait réfléchir vous
êtes dit je vais pas faire la même
erreur exactement ça donc vous êtes dit
moi je voilà je sais pas ce que vous
écriviez parce que si vous voulez il y a
des limites à l'influence même vous avez
raison je vendais beaucoup de livres
j'avais des traditions
mais il y a une limite si vous voulez on
est on s'engage on sent comment vous
dire on est dans le rôle de Cassandre
vous savez Cassan elle annonce le
malheur au grec et les Grecs n'écoute
jamais et ben c'est exactement ce qui
m'arrivait et donc je me suis dit
puisque personne ne m'écoute je veux
dire dans la classe politique puisque
personne ne ne ne voit la catastrophe
qui arrive et n'ose engagé ce combat
pour éviter la mort de la France et ben
moi il faut que j'y aille on va reparler
dans un instant on va vous mettre face à
la cuve ce qui se passe énormément de
choses bien entendu actuellement mais
pour l'instant on va parler du livre je
n'ai pas dit mon dernier mot votre
nouveau livre le titre est clair je n'ai
pas dit mon dernier mot c'est parce que
vous allez participer à qui veut gagner
des millions ou vous allez continuer
vous représenter non je évidemment je
continue le combat politique en fait
vous savez j'ai découvert après avoir
écrit sleep parce que les gens croient
toujours que on sait d'avance que ce
qu'on pense quand on quand on écrit un
livre en fait c'est l'inverse on
comprend ce qu'on pense quand on a écrit
on l'a écrit et là j'ai compris quelque
chose en fait j'avais toujours fait la
même chose c'est-à-dire que je mène
toujours le même combat depuis on veut
dire 20 ans 30 ans mais avec des armes
différentes alors au début c'était le
journaliste politique classique
après ça a été le journaliste radio télé
les livres et aujourd'hui je rajoute à
cela un parti politique mais je pense
que c'est toujours le même combat je
pense que vous savez les journalistes
ont beaucoup bassiné avec il n'a pas
fait ça mue il n'a pas fait sa mue je
vais vous dire la vérité je crois que
c'était grotesque
il n'y a pas de mue à faire on mène un
combat on fait de la politique il y a
beaucoup de gens qui font de la
politique sont l'avouer le problème
qu'on a avec les journalistes il y en a
un qui dit quelque chose les autres
suivent derrière ça c'est le côté
moutonnier vous savez Régis Debré disait
qu'est-ce qu'un journaliste c'est
quelqu'un qui lit les autres
journalistes après il y en a qui sont
bien mais c'est vrai que la plupart
voilà c'est ils comprennent voilà vous
avez vu que dans mon livre je ne
exactement une analyse globale et
complète je crois des médias justement
on va en parler dans un instant
2027 vous serez candidat
on verra mais je n'exclut pas d'être
candidat si vous continuez votre parti
politique si je continue si on verra il
y a d'autres échéances avant
vous a fait mal la défaite ou pas parce
que quand vous êtes monté à 18%, moi je
me rappelle d'ici j'avais j'avais Jordan
Bardella qui était là et je lui ai dit
vous étiez à 18 % de sondages je lui ai
dit vous avez pas l'impression que Éric
Zemmour va manger Marine Le Pen à ce
moment-là est-ce que vous êtes pas dit à
18%
je vais être au deuxième tour je vais je
vais être face à Emmanuel Macron c'est
sûr je me suis dit même deux fois vous
savez j'ai été dans les sondages au
second tour en octobre et j'ai été de
nouveau en février oui c'est sûr que je
vais vous faire une confidence je
préparais mon débat avec Emmanuel Macron
dans ma tête
est-ce que vous avez des regrets est-ce
qu'il y a parce que un moment
c'est vrai qu'à un moment moi tous les
soirs je faisais un sujet sur vous
d'ailleurs on me l'a reproché vous avez
vu on me l'a dit je parlais trop de vous
forcément parce que vous étiez le seul
candidat à faire parler de vous parce
qu'à un moment Mélenchon il est rentré
très tard dans la campagne Mélenchon un
moment il était inexistant jusqu'à la
fin comme d'habitude il fait toujours
des remontada mais il est toujours porte
de la finale Marine Le Pen elle est elle
était c'était voilà c'est vrai qu'à un
moment vous l'avez vous avez pris toute
la place et c'est vrai qu'à un moment
moi je parlais de vous tous les jours et
c'est vrai que c'est monter monter
monter monter deux questions est-ce que
vous avez des regrets est-ce que je sais
que une élection c'est un marathon et
c'est vrai que j'avais parlé avec
nombreux de nombreux spécialistes qui
m'ont dit peut-être qu'Eric Zemmour est
parti trop vite et que il a fait un 100
mètres alors que c'est un marathon
est-ce que vous est-ce que vous vous
dites parce que c'était la première fois
peut-être que vous avez pas faire la
même erreur
vous avez vos spécialistes que vous avez
consultés ont tout à fait raison mais je
pense que j'étais obligé parce que je
n'avais pas de d'histoire politique
donc déjà il faut que tu et c'est vrai
que vous vous partiez avec cet avantage
mais à un moment est-ce qu'il y a une
phrase ou un voilà une sortie dans une
interview où vous êtes dit celle-là
j'aurais peut-être pas dû la faire et ça
fait que peut-être voilà ça c'est ça
c'est isolé derrière oui j'aurais je
vais vous dire je pense que vous avez vu
il y a un chapitre qui s'appelle mea
culpa donc je je lis mes erreurs vous
avez parlé de Valérie Pécresse je pense
que j'ai mal réagi dans le débat où elle
a voulu
pourrir le débat et j'ai bêtement suivi
c'est à dire que je me suis énervé
bêtement même chez vous avec Mélenchon
il a il a invectivé tout le temps et
j'ai fini par m'énerver ça c'est des
erreurs j'aurais pas dû des phrases sans
doute je me suis très mal expliqué sur
les réfugiés Ukrainiens
je pense que on a pris pour de la dureté
alors que ça se voulait de la pédagogie
c'est-à-dire que moi spontanément
j'avais envie de dire et bah très bien
ce sont des Européens des femmes et des
donc on les accueille en plus
provisoirement puisque de tous les
repartir et je me suis dit oui mais on
va me dire pourquoi vous n'accueillez
pas par exemple les Syriens les Afghans
etc et du coup je me suis moi-même dit
bah non alors on accueille personne ça
n'a pas été compris du tout même chez
moi il y a des choses il y a des choses
que vous auriez pu préciser il y a eu
d'autres sorties ce qui est à quel
moment vous êtes dit où il a là j'ai la
peut-être la chose sans toi là j'ai j'ai
handicapée des enfants handicapés
alors non mais c'est une très bonne si
vous me permettez
handicapé c'est une très bonne
intervention alors là on va on va
rappeler ce qu'il avait dit oui
justement non permettez-moi de rappeler
parce que je vais le mettre vraiment
vous allez voir le plus honnête possible
je suis à une réunion avec des
professeurs les enseignants qui sont là
qui m'expliquent on est il y a une
dizaine d'enseignants qui me disent
leurs problèmes et on parle pendant une
heure essentiellement si vous voulez de
la baisse du niveau scolaire et je leur
dis mais mes diagnostics et je leur dis
mais solutions en gros en gros pour
aller vite parce qu'on va pas refaire le
débat d'une heure que j'ai eu avec eux
en gros je leur dis le problème c'est le
collège unique c'est qu'on mélange des
enfants de niveau très différents et ça
empêche les bons d'être bon parce qu'il
s'ennuient et les mauvais en vérité
n'arrivent pas à suivre le niveau bref
vous avez compris et je dis c'est
l'obsession de l'inclusion quel problème
de l'école actuelle et à la fin je vous
dis vraiment à l'extrême fin c'est à
dire on allait j'allais me lever il y a
une professeure qui dit ah mais moi vous
savez j'ai vraiment des problèmes avec
on me met dans ma classe des enfants
handicapés et c'est un vrai problème
j'ai pas été formé pour ça les pauvres
gosses ils ont un mal fou à suivre moi
je n'arrive pas je peux pas m'occuper de
tout le monde et puisque c'était la fin
donc je conclus d'une formule un peu
rapide et je dis ben vous voyez madame
c'est ce que j'ai dit c'est l'obsession
de l'inclusion c'est pauvres enfants
tout le monde souffre dans cette
histoire et par une polémique monstreuse
on prend que vous me dit les gens
handicapé de l'école voilà on me dit que
je veux sortir les handicapés de l'école
mais comme Bendit ira jusqu'à dire que
je suis pire kitler parce qu'au moins
hitler n'a pas tué les handicapés sous
pression de l'église vous voyez jusqu'où
c'est monté et là j'ai fini le journal
de France 2 fait 3 minutes dans laquelle
il montre ma phrase sortie de ton
contexte et il invite la ministre de
handicap Sophie Cluzel qui se met à
pleurer en disant c'est scandaleux ce
qu'il a dit c'est un monstre moi j'ai
une enfant handicapé on veut la sortir
de l'école etc
mes équipes appellent le journal de
France 2 en disant on peut un droit de
réponse vous savez la réponse de des
équipes de France 2 ah bah non on va
quand même pas parler du handicap toute
la semaine donc si vous voulez ça c'est
je le raconte dans mon chapitre sur les
médias j'ai je vous assure j'ai reçu des
milliers de lettres ou de mails de
parents me disant vous avez tout à fait
raison en fait vous savez ce que c'est
que cette histoire et on en parlera plus
on va s'arrêter là c'est un une combine
pour ne pas ouvrir des écoles
spécialisées pour les enfants handicapés
qu'on a vraiment besoin parce qu'il y a
des enfants handicapés qui peuvent aller
à l'école parce que avec les autres mais
il y a des enfants qui ne peuvent pas
les peaux et eux comme ça coûte beaucoup
plus cher vous savez ce qu'ils font ils
vont en Belgique voilà c'est ça la
France aujourd'hui et c'est ça le procès
qu'on m'a fait j'avais eu Sophie Cluzel
après cette affaire elle elle avait
vraiment pris pour c'est vrai qu'elle
avait une enfant handicapée et elle mais
bien sûr
voilà d'une façon à ce qu'elle Sophie
elle a vraiment touché et c'est
quelqu'un d'assez sincère et de sincère
Sophie et c'est vrai que voilà elle est
dans son combat à fond et on peut pas
l'enlever mais c'est vrai qu'ils l'ont
vendu d'une telle façon que c'est vrai
que ça va énormément touché on va
revenir sur votre livret sur les
passages choc du livre vous revenez nos
morts donc sur ce qui a motivé petit à
petit votre candidature on en a parlé il
y a un instant on me demande souvent
quel fut l'événement voilà qui est
entraîné ma décision de me présenter mes
interlocuteurs ne me crois pas quand je
leur réponds qu'il n'y en a pas je dis
pourtant la vérité il n'y a pas eu
d'événements fondateurs ou plutôt il y
en a une multitude petit à petit la
décision s'est imposée je ne suis
progressivement mis dans l'impossibilité
de reculer parce que c'est vrai qu'on a
eu un le sentiment que vous donniez
énormément votre avis tous les soirs
tous les matins voilà ça la radio à la
télévision et on a l'impression que
c'est c'est vraiment ce sont les les
journalistes les les les les les le
peuple qui s'est qui vous a dit bon
peut-être qu'il faut que tu te présentes
c'est à dire que c'est il faudrait
limite donner l'idée est-ce que vous
l'aviez au départ ou même pas non pas du
tout je j'avais pas du tout cette idée
je raconte que c'est une longue
évolution à partir du succès de mon
livre le suicide français vous vous
souvenez en 2014 on a commencé à me le
dire et puis ça a calé en montant en
montant en montant et je vous le dis moi
en fait ce qui m'a décidé c'est que
depuis des années et on va en parler
librement et tranquillement d'ailleurs
je crains pour la disparition de la
France je pèse mes mots et je me dis il
va y avoir un politique qui va se lever
et qui va prendre ce flambeau et je n'en
trouve jamais donc à la fin je me suis
dit je ne peux pas me regarder en face
je ne peux pas laisser à mes enfants
cette ce cet angoisse là il faut que je
prenne ça sur moi et je finis par me
lancer vous dites justement l'apostrophe
sur le ton de l'évidence de mon fils
papa le constat tu l'as fait faut
maintenant passer à l'action le travail
inlassable de Sarah knafu la foule des
soutiens qui affluaient le nombre de
plus en plus important de Français qui
espérait en moi la décision du CSA qui
m'expulsait de la télévision les crins
du Figaro qui me forçait à quitter le
journal Albin Michel qui refusait de me
publier on me jetait dans le vide mais
on me reproche me reprocher de sauter
donc voilà donc vous avez remarqué que
que tous ces événements
ce sont déroulés avant même que vous
présente à l'élection présidentielle
c'est à dire que il y avait vraiment un
si vous voulez en gros il y a une
campagne pendant les six mois qui ont
précédé parce que vu mes audiences vont
vous souvenez etc mais vous avez connu
ça comme moi c'était il faut le faire
taire il faut le faire taire il faut
comptabiliser son temps de parole etc
etc et donc évidemment à la fin mais
vous avez connu ça comme moi vous avez
le CSA sur le dos vous avez les journaux
qui vous disent non mais là on peut plus
garder vous avez y compris au Figaro la
société des rédacteurs et les syndicats
qui me tapent dessus tous les jours vous
voyez c'est un enchaînement l'éditeur
qui me dit ah ben non on veut pas de
publier parce que c'est pour te lancer à
la présidentielle je lui dis maintenant
je comprends pas il y a 50 à publier
Fillon avec un livre il se présentait
pas la présidentielle lui voyez c'est
un engrenage inexorable on se dit bon
bah
7% vous étiez déçu ou pas ah oui
vraiment vous savez quand on est monté
je vous dis deux fois les sondeurs m'ont
expliqué c'est déjà mais c'était du
jamais vu jusqu'à 18-19 qu'on est au
second tour à deux reprises évidemment
que je suis déçu vous savez moi je suis
j'aime je suis un sportif j'aime j'aime
gagner je déteste perdre j'ai j'ai vu la
tête de Mbappé le après la finale de la
Coupe du monde ça m'a fait plaisir je me
suis dit ben voilà un combattant un type
qui qui déteste la défaite et ben moi
aussi je déteste la défaite je me suis
battu j'ai perdu franchement j'étais pas
heureux non alors vous réglez vos
comptes aussi avec la droite dans ce
livre notamment avec Robert Ménard
chaque fois qu'on me communique une
déclare le maire de Béziers chaque fois
qu'on communique une déclaration de
Robert Ménard à mon propos j'entends
aussitôt la voix rocailleuse et
goguenarde de Charles Pasqua qui me
souffle de l'au-delà avec des amis comme
ça on n'a pas besoin d'ennemis Robert
Ménard un carnet ainsi la figure pure
est parfaite du traître celle qu'on
trouve tout au long de l'histoire de
France vous savez pourquoi je me suis
j'ai quelques pages sur mena mais c'est
pas pour la personne de Ménard c'est
pour ce qui l'incarne c'est-à-dire il a
passé son temps à expliquer que j'étais
pas gentil que j'étais méchant que
j'étais brutale mon si vous voulez ce
qui m'intéresse là dedans c'est comment
les médias utilisent le sentiment voyez
la personnalisation le psychologisme
juste fou pour
délégitimer pour dénigrer des idées et
un et un projet pour la France on passe
par le personnel et Ménard s'est laissé
instrumentaliser avec joie pour dire Ah
bah non il est méchant c'est comme si
vous savez on serait je ne me compare
pas je vous préviens d'avance mais
imaginez tous les jours on dit le
général de Gaulle est méchant le général
de Gaulle n'aime pas ceci le général de
Gaulle n'aime pas les gens voyez etc etc
je suis encore une fois je ne me compare
pas au général de Gaulle mais c'est pour
vous dire l'ambiance on utilise le
personnel le sentiment pour ne pas
combattre les idées mais pour
délégitimer la personne qui les porte ça
vous en vélo et vous en voulez dégâts
pour ça c'est vrai que c'est une des
méthodes vous avez vu je les listes dans
terre mais c'est une des méthodes
utilisées par les médias pour
délégitimer un candidat et pour choisir
en vérité ce que j'ai compris je l'avais
déjà compris d'ailleurs avec François
Fillon les médias non seulement
choisissent les candidats qui doivent
appeler aux Français mais en plus
maintenant ils veulent même choisir le
thème c'est-à-dire que comme moi les
médias ils vous ont fait attendez
attendez attendez oui je vais répondre à
ça
je vais vous dire je vais vous dire la
vérité
Eric Éric je vous dis la vérité mais
arrêtez de dire arrêtez de dire les
médias vous avez raison Eric je vais
vous dire la vérité ça les arrange à
chaque fois que vous passez quelque part
vous faisiez des records de nuances pour
arrêter de prendre pour des cons donc
les médias vous ont fait les médias les
médias l'ont fait et je suis d'accord et
je vais te dire les médias qui faisaient
à votre existence vous avez raison je
vais vous répondre mais bien sûr
effectivement
c'est parce que je faisais de l'audience
mais oui et là vous il y a un point
important quand même à partir du moment
où je suis arrivé parce qu'au début
j'étais rien je veux dire mon premier
sondage je fais 3 % honnête bon et je
monte je monte je monte à partir du
moment où je monte à 18 19 et que je
suis au second tour
l'attitude des médias change et comme
vous avez tout à fait raison ils sont
moutonnés évidemment tout le monde se
rue sur moi donc vous avez raison et
j'ai raison ils m'ont fait et ensuite
ils m'ont défait et surtout ce qui est
important j'insiste c'est la raison ils
ont voulu m'arracher mon thème c'est à
dire qu'ils ont voulu montrer je le
développe dans le livre que le grand
remplacement n'était pas le sujet majeur
qui s'opposait aux Français et que donc
l'important c'était le pouvoir d'achat
et que donc je n'avais rien à faire dans
cette présidentielle c'est ce que je
veux dire les médias veulent choisir non
seulement le candidat mais aussi le
thème qui qui s'impose aux Français mais
vous connaissiez ça puisque vous êtes
vous-même issus des médias alors je vais
vous dire vous avez raison j'ai plus de
30 ans de journalistes politiques donc
je suis inexcusable mais j'ai encore
sous-estimé la puissance de feu je
pensais vous savez que les gens
résisteraient mieux je me suis rendu
compte que en fait les gens sont assez
crédules et que ils sont assez
paradoxaux d'ailleurs ils détestent les
journalistes et en même temps il répète
motamo ce que les journalistes non mais
c'est pas de la faute des gens
un moment souple
comme ça qui dit toujours la même chose
je veux dire on en est victime aussi
enfin victime on n'aurait pas victime
parce que plus les journalistes parlent
de nous après nous c'est certain il y a
on va pas mettre tous les jours aussi
dans le dans le même sac non mais je
vais vous dire voilà moi je prends
souvent l'exemple de de France Inter
France Inter c'est vrai que si vous
écoutez toute la journée France Inter
vous allez tantôt traîner et vous allez
avoir une pensée unique et vous allez
avoir la pensée de France Inter qui est
du matin au soir vont vous faire croire
des choses et vont taper sur les gilets
jaunes et vont taper sur les antivax
vont taper sur des diras où qui est
méchant et qui est une mauvaise personne
vont taper sur Éric Zemmour vont taper
sur toujours les mêmes donc forcément
c'est vrai que voilà il y a des médias
comme ça où il y a pas de contradiction
je vais vous dire vous avez raison c'est
pas une question individuelle en vérité
c'est pas une question de journaliste
c'est pour ça que je parle de système
c'est à dire que il y a une pression une
pression collective qui commence à
l'école de journaliste
j'ai l'autre jour dîner avec un ami dont
le fils était à l'école de journalisme
il cache que il a voté pour moi il me
dit mais sinon je suis mort
et ça continue dans les rédactions dans
les rédactions c'est la même pression et
ça j'ai connu ça en revanche je le
savais c'est à dire qu'il y a une
pression moi quand j'étais jeune il
fallait suivre la ligne du monde et de
libération quand j'étais jeune
journaliste et aujourd'hui ils ont BFM
en boucle et ils doivent suivre
obligatoirement la ligne de BFM il y a
une pression collective qui est très
forte et auquel peut résister
est-ce que vous êtes pas trompé
justement parce que vous dites oui les
médias ils ont voulu absolument parler
du pouvoir d'achat alors que moi mon
cheval de bataille c'était le grand
remplacement mais les événements
aujourd'hui prouvent que peut-être que
les médias avaient raison de parler
finalement du pouvoir d'achat et pas du
grand remplacement
moi je suis désolé Ah non je suis pas
d'accord les médias ils ne parlaient que
du Grand remplacement parce que ça
faisait plus de buzz que le pouvoir
d'achat je suis désolé donc monsieur
Zemmour s'est trompé non
ah bah vous savez il y a différentes
temporalités
le pouvoir d'achat c'est un sujet à la
fois d'actualité et de toujours
ont des problèmes de fin de mois c'est
ils ont pas toujours des grosses payes
ils ont en plus je pense que nous sommes
un pays qui s'appauvrit mais on en
reparlera donc évidemment que le pouvoir
d'achat c'est un problème quotidien et
en l'occurrence là il y avait un moment
avec l'inflation avec la guerre en
Ukraine qui a gravé cela etc mais
l'élection présidentielle
c'est le destin de la France qui se joue
le général de Gaulle l'a voulu ainsi ce
ne sont pas seulement des questions
matérielles qui ont leur importance
évidemment moi j'ai voulu mettre
l'accent sur le destin de la France
c'est-à-dire à 10 ans à 15 ans c'est ça
normalement la fonction de l'élection
présidentielle alors oui il y a des
problèmes de pouvoir d'achat il y a
aussi des problèmes économiques il y a
d'ailleurs j'en ai parlé énormément
contrairement à ce qu'on a raconté vous
savez j'ai fait 7 discours sur
l'économie j'ai fait deux ou trois
discours uniquement sur le pouvoir
d'achat donc j'avais des solutions et
qui était d'ailleurs beaucoup plus
efficace que celles qui ont été
présentées parce que celles qui ont été
présentées c'était une course
démagogique a toujours de faire des
chèques moi je faisais une vraie un vrai
programme de production et de baisse des
charges pour que les gens aient moins de
charges et de taxes à payer vous voyez
donc j'avais un programme aussi mais
ma priorité de la priorité c'était le
destin de la France parce que le pouvoir
d'achat c'est important mais quand le
pays aura une toute autre nature quand
il sera islamisé quand on aura plus les
mêmes la même
nature du pays on peut en parler
tranquillement je veux dire c'est on va
en parler on va et là là ça sera
important le pouvoir d'achat toujours
est-ce que
Eric Zemmour vous voyez elle a dit vous
avez mis 15 minutes à parler de l'islam
est-ce que vous pensez pas que c'est pas
ça qui vous a coûté aussi les 10 points
que vous avez perdu ah vous savez alors
là je ne pense pas je ne pense pas je
pense que vous savez je suis monté vous
avez dit je suis monté à 18 19 en
septembre octobre c'est là où je n'ai
parlé et c'était volontaire parce que je
voulais imposer mon sujet que du grand
emplacement et d'islam et d'immigration
c'est après que j'ai parlé d'autre chose
donc c'est pas ça qui m'a fait descendre
après je pense que après je pense que
c'était vous vous étiez toujours
là-dessus est-ce que c'est ce qu'il y
avait pas renouvellement voilà je viens
de monde je n'étais pas toujours
là-dessus à partir de janvier j'ai parlé
d'autres choses j'ai parlé d'économie
j'ai parlé de ruralité j'ai parlé de
défense nationale j'ai parlé de
politique étrangère voyez j'ai parlé de
beaucoup d'autres sujets mais là où vous
avez raison et on en revient toujours à
notre discussion d'origine c'est que les
médias n'en parlaient pas donc on
parlait vous êtes une victime alors
comment vous êtes une victime des médias
non non victime non mais en tout cas je
pense que les médias ont été mon
adversaire
m'ont battu et abattu alors
volontairement Éric Zemmour je pense que
si je je pense que c'est qu'il y avait
il y a des sujets et je le pense aussi
pour les médias qui je vais vous dire
Eric Zemmour qui fait une sortie sur le
grand remplacement Islam forcément et
moi c'est ça que j'aimerais j'aimerais
qu'il le dise franchement qui le disent
à un moment les médias oui on veut faire
de l'audience oui on veut faire du buzz
oui on veut qui est le plus de monde qui
est le plus de monde qui nous regardent
je suis désolé il y a une hypocrisie
autour de vous aussi les gens prenaient
que ce sujet je le dis parce que ils
savent très bien que Eric Zemmour qui
parle de l'inflation ou Éric Zemmour qui
parle d'autre chose que de
l'islamisation ou du Grand remplacement
et bah ça marche pas je suis désolé les
mecs et on l'a fait et on l'a fait et on
est les premiers à l'avoir fait oui oui
mais merci merci pour les médias oui ça
marche aussi pour éviter ça oui mais
bien sûr
tout le monde vous lire xemmour sur son
plateau moi je me rappelle je vous dis
ils ont même fait des décomptes nous
comme quoi on a trop parlé de vous mais
je vais vous dire Eric Zemmour tous les
jours il était partout tous les médias
on se verrait avec Zemmour et à chaque
fois que vous receviez Eric Zemmour
c'était des record d'audience donc un
moment il faut arrêter aussi
l'hypocrisie autour des Rick Zemmour
voilà on veut l'éviter mais on peut pas
l'inviter mais on l'invite parce que ça
fait de l'audience voilà faut arrêter un
moment voilà juste pour parler de Marine
Le Pen aussi dans le livre vous dites
Marine Le Pen a tant subi la
marginalisation la caricature la vie de
paria le rejet de l'enfance autant de
choses que je n'ai pas connu que pour se
faire adouber elle est prête à tout cela
explique aussi que Marine Le Pen a mis
tant d'énergie à reproduire contre moi
ce qu'elle avait même elle-même subit
toute sa vie elle s'est opposée à moi
comme le système c'était opposé à elle
vous l'avez fait peur en pensez au début
oui je pense beaucoup oui j'ai découvert
d'ailleurs que certains voulaient aller
la voir pour lui dire de se retirer si
elle continuait à baisser oui je pense
qu'elle a eu peur et que d'ailleurs ce
qui explique beaucoup son comportement
vis-à-vis de moi alors que je vais vous
dire au départ moi
je ne voulais pas d'une primaire
contre Marine Le Pen là encore ce sont
les médias qui ont voulu inventer une
primaire dite d'extrême droite penser et
vous voulez lui l'Union des droites moi
non moi je voulais si vous voulez moi je
suis vous savez je suis de tradition
gaulisme Golo bonapartiste pour être
savant j'ai écrit 4 livres sur le RPR la
droite Jacques Chirac j'ai pas écrit un
seul livre sur le front national je ne
sais pas ma famille moi ma famille c'est
la droite gaulliste et quand j'ai
commencé d'ailleurs la campagne j'ai dit
simplement Marine Le Pen ne peut pas
gagner tout le monde le sait il faut
arrêter l'hypocrisie c'est ce qui
d'ailleurs ce qui s'est passé mais en
revanche il faut dans mon premier
discours de Villepinte
je parle pas je ne parle pas de marine
je parle de Valérie Pécresse et des
trahisons de la droite shirakienne
depuis 20 ans pardon c'est même ma
spécialité de journaliste politique Éric
Zemmour donc c'est ça ce que vous dites
donc vous auriez pas pu être le candidat
de la droite traditionnelle mais j'ai
même songé cher Cyril Hanouna à me
présenter à la primaire voilà bah oui
parce que je pense que ça aurait été
bien sûr sauf que vous avez raison j'ai
pensé oui mais un moment c'est il y a
deux trois sorties qui ont fait qui
pouvaient pas vous accepter non c'est
des prétextes sur
ils ont tellement eu peur que je gagne
parce que je vous rappelle quand même
Éric Ciotti a fait
40%, il me l'a dit lui-même uniquement
en donnant en me citant dans tous ces
meetings et en disant que il me
soutiendrait au second tour de la
présidentielle si j'y étais il me l'a
dit lui-même il fait 40 %
bon donc je pense que oui j'aurais gagné
la primaire de LR mais ils ont bloqué
mon arrivée ils ont trouvé des prétextes
des des des des des trucs Jurid japonais
la noix l'archet a fait ce qu'il fallait
voilà Gérard pardon Gérard lâcher
président du Sénat donc voilà donc je
n'ai pas pu me présenter mais au départ
c'était ma famille politique et depuis
20 ans depuis 30 ans et le livre dont je
vous parle le livreur de la droite il
date de 97 c'est vous dire ou déjà je
décortique et je déconstruis les
trahisons de la droite chiracienne et
pourquoi
ils vont à la mort donc c'est maintenant
ce qui arrive
vous savez j'ai des pardonnez-moi je
veux répondre à ça parce que j'ai des
amis c'est mes amis j'ai grandi avec
leurs aînés avec Philippe Seguin avec
Charles Pasqua ils m'ont appris la
politique j'ai des amis à LR des amis
nombreux il y a des gens qui qui pensent
vraiment tout comme moi vous trouverez
difficilement des différences avec Bruno
Retailleau avec Olivier Marley ça existe
bien sûr à la marge avec Éric Ciotti
avec d'autres donc ne me dites pas ça je
leur tape dessus parce que je dis ce que
beaucoup pensaient de LR d'ailleurs là
entre nous beaucoup savent que elle est
mort là vous avez vu c'est c'est
la fin
c'est un système que je dénonce et le
système de la soumission au centre qui
se soumet lui-même à la gauche et donc
qui amène la droite à gauche c'est juste
Éric Zemmour est-ce que Marine Le Pen
aurait fait une meilleure prosidente que
que Emmanuel Macron mais
Marine Le Pen ne n'aurait pas pu et ne
peut pas d'après moi être élu voilà
concrètement
qu'Emmanuel Macron lui non plus il ne
peut pas être élu je me suis présenté
aussi c'était la deuxième raison pour
sortir de ce jeu de posture et
d'imposture qui fait gagner Emmanuel
Macron
Marine Le Pen comme Jean-Luc Mélenchon
font gagner Emmanuel Macron face à eux
ils gagnent et face à Marine Le Pen il
gagnera toujours et le candidat
macronise gagnera toujours contrairement
à ce que disent les les commentateurs
voilà ce que je pense et voilà pourquoi
je me souviens
de casser cette malédiction du cordon
sanitaire vous avez vu aujourd'hui les
députés ils sont justement
à quoi il servent parce que vous pensez
d'utilisation du 49-3 il a de la motion
de censure qui n'est pas passée à 9 mois
près donc ce qui veut dire que donc la
réforme des retraites va passer voilà et
que il y avait une motion de censure à
la motion de censure c'est un moyen de
contrôle du gouvernement par l'Assemblée
nationale il aurait fallu qui est la
majorité voilà qui vote cette motion de
censure et là c'est on repart à zéro et
là c'est on redistribue les cartes donc
la motion de censure n'a pas été
voté donc là la réforme des retraites
passe à coup sûr qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez écoutez
il faut bien comprendre quelque chose
parce que je me je discute avec les gens
depuis plusieurs jours il y a une
confusion qui est faite
Emmanuel Macron n'est pas en jeu dans
cette histoire
si la motion de censure était passée
Emmanuel Macron n'aurait pas dû
démissionner pour lui ça n'aurait rien
changé mais parce que vous comprenez il
y a une confusion dans la tête des gens
ils sont tellement furieux et moi avec
contre Emmanuel Macron que ils veulent à
tout prix la battre mais la motion de
censure et le 49.3 n'aurait rien changé
il aurait qu'est-ce qu'il aurait fait si
la motion de censurer était passé soit
il aurait renommé madame porn j'aurais
pu soit il aurait changé de Premier
ministre soit il aurait changé de
Premier ministre et il aurait dissous
mais lui il restait à l'Elysée
c'est une histoire moi je ne suis pas à
l'Assemblée donc je vais pas me poser
des questions qui ne se posent pas oui
enfin c'est facile
mais vous savez d'habitude c'est pas
pratique et vous êtes d'habitude vous
êtes pas l'assemblée c'est nul etc donc
deuxièmement je vous répète
moi ce qui m'a frappé je vais vous dire
à l'Assemblée
c'est pas le vote de cette motion de
censure c'est le désordre le scandale le
ce que j'appelle moi la nupcisation des
esprits vous avez remarqué tout le monde
s'aligne sur la nupestres tout le monde
pense comme la nupes vous avez remarqué
que le RN pense comme la nups utilise
les mots de la nups et les la moitié ou
le tiers des députés LR maintenant prend
des aires de gauchistes alors qu'ils ont
soutenu François Fillon il y a il y a 6
ans et il est allérée peut-être pour les
retraites à 65 ans et que vous avez vu
qu'ils étaient prêts à voter avec le
rassemblement national alors que cela
même qui évoque le cordon sanitaire et
qui disent qu'il faut pas toucher au
rassemblement national etc oui on est
vraiment dans le royaume des postures et
des impostures et moi je trouve que ça
donne une image mais détestable de du
Parlement de la représentation nationale
franchement j'ai pas envie de mettre mon
doigt là dedans c'est pour ça que je
vous réponds comme ça avec Zemmour Cyril
Hanouna vous pouvez la question cette
censure est repoussée à neuf fois prêt
est-ce que c'est pas en réalité le pire
scénario pour le gouvernement c'est à
dire une rue qui va continuer sans doute
à contester en attendant peut-être que
le Conseil constitutionnel puisse
retoquer ou pas certaines mesures ce
qu'il y aurait une majorité de 15 ou 20
bon très bien mais là 8 9 ça veut dire
qu'en fait même l'Assemblée nationale
qui pour son seul vote sur cette réforme
c'est pas séries craque donc est-ce que
c'est pas la pire des situations pour le
gouvernement c'est sûr qu'Emmanuel
Macron et son gouvernement sont
considérablement affaiblis ils vont
avoir du mal maintenant à présenter
d'autres textes puisque manifestement LR
ne tient plus rien dire il y a autant de
de d'opinion que de députés LR c'est
vraiment c'est ce que je vous disais
tout à l'heure quoi c'est un parti en
fin de route bon
mais pour Emmanuel Macron encore une
fois moi je vais vous dire je comprends
la colère contre Emmanuel Macron moi
quand vous demandez aux gens moi j'ai
dit et je vais être honnête avec vous je
l'ai dit dans mon programme il y avait
le relèvement d'âge à 64 donc je vais
pas
faire celui qui était contre mais moi
j'étais pour faire des économies oui
pour sauver le régime de répartition oui
mais dans un dans une dans une comment
vous dire dans une politique globale je
mettais en œuvre une politique de
natalité familiale une politique de
réindustrialisation politique de lutte
contre la fraude et quand vous voyez
qu'Emmanuel Macron il se réveille le
matin il doit même un milliard à un pays
africain il se réveille en août matin il
donne un milliard à l'Ukraine mais les
gens deviennent fous ils se disent mais
c'est pas possible il dit la pile notre
argent et après il nous demande de
travailler deux ans pour économiser 15
ou 17 milliards je comprends que ça
énerve vous voyez ça veut dire moi aussi
ça m'énerve cette question de timing
aussi comme on en a parlé ici c'est vrai
que le timing était et pas et pas fou
fou dans votre livre Éric Zemmour depuis
l'apparition du lit d'ailleurs une des
choses dont on parle le plus c'est votre
relation avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon tu as
eu l'occasion de voir tous les deux vous
avez fait un débat vous en avez fait
deux même avec moi chez moi ici et tu
connais Jean-Luc Mélenchon depuis des
années il était alors membre du Parti
socialiste et moi journaliste nos orig
une commune de l'autre côté de la
Méditerranée et même un goût pour
l'histoire nous ont rapproché je crois
pouvoir dire que nous étions ce qu'on
appelle de bons copains il était là
lorsque j'ai fêté mes 50 ans et nous
nous tenions dans une estime réciproque
qui lui finir un jour à la télévision je
connais très bien Éric Zemmour ce n'est
pas un raciste il est c'est un brillant
intellectuel on a l'extrait quand il le
dit regardez connaissez-vous il ferait
mieux de dire qu'il a dit une bêtise ce
type n'est pas un raciste est un c'est
un brillant intellectuel mais il est
comme tous les intellectuels têtu comme
une mule ce qu'il a dit et comme il l'a
dit n'est pas bien dit voilà c'est tout
ce qu'il faut qu'il dise maintenant
alors on apprend aussi qu'il était bien
content que vous vous présentiez que
vous vous parliez encore même si le
candidat de la France insoumise est
complètement parano ce que vous dites
c'est toi qui s'assoit à temps parle pas
ici appelle-moi avec cette autre numéro
sur télégramme Jean-Luc Mélenchon est
prudent plus encore il est méfiant
suspicieux les jeunes diraient qu'il est
parano je ne peux m'empêcher de songer à
Staline qui disait-on changer
d'appartement chaque soir il a reconnu
ma voix comme j'ai reconnu la sienne
mais il préfère prendre des précautions
puis au fil des appels qui se
multiplient il se livrera davantage avec
quand vous vous il était en stress les
premières fois c'est ça alors pour venir
aussi sur le grand débat que vous avez
vécu sur BFM TV j'ai souhaité le
contacter en ce mois de septembre radio
pour lui faire une proposition qui ne
pourra pas refuser il veut devenir le
patron des gauches cela tombe bien je
veux faire l'union des électeurs de
droite je pressens qu'un débat l'un
contre l'autre peut nous permettre de
rameuter nos camps respectifs et de
montrer la France que le clivage
droite-gauche est plus que jamais actuel
je n'ai pas besoin de lui expliquer
l'intérêt ce débat longtemps il comprend
il sait déjà et accepte rapidement
donc ça c'était ce fameux débat sur BFM
c'était le 23 septembre 2021 c'était le
jour de mon anniversaire si vous avez
fait ça pour moi
donc c'est vrai et Jean-Luc Mélenchon il
vous attaque direct ce jour-là dès la
première question des journalistes là
donc Mélenchon a répondu il dit que il a
dit qu'il n'était pas l'ami d'Éric
Zemmour qu'il détestait ce que vous
racontiez et cependant rapidement
plusieurs personnalités politiques ont
réagi sur les réseaux sociaux ils
accultent Mélenchon de menteurs Jean-Luc
Mélenchon comme il respire Eric Naulleau
qui dit ça je lui connaissances des
messages amicaux et même fraternel qu'il
adressait Eric Zemmour pour le
conseiller sur sa campagne
présidentielle il renie son amitié
envers lui comme il l'avait fait envers
Cyril Hanouna je peux en témoigner
Mohamed Sifaoui Jean-Luc Mélenchon ment
lorsqu'on septembre 2010 je publie un
livre pour dénoncer le discours d'Éric
Zemmour Mélenchon que je croisais dans
un meeting organisé par SOS Racisme
interpellé pour me dire ne t'attaque pas
Zemmour c'est mon ami
et d'autres voilà Éric Eric Zemmour je
suis dans un café début de campagne sur
son téléphone s'affiche le nom de JLM
qu'il appelle Eric répond et par 3
mètres plus loin je le vois rire pendant
10 minutes la conversation est très
détendue Jean-Luc Mélenchon assumé c'est
pas grave
alors
les témoignages vous avez tous compris
mais essayons d'aller plus au fond oui
c'était un ami je parle d'une époque
quand même mis à 10 ans mais bon on a le
droit de changer moi quand j'ai connu
Jean-Luc Mélenchon
on était on avait des points d'accord
c'était l'époque où il estimait que on
pouvait critiquer l'islam ouistitimait
qu'il était pour le nucléaire aussi on
estimait aussi il se moquait des femmes
voilées il disait qu'elle s'auto
stigmatisées il a changé en vérité comme
la gauche et Jean-Luc Mélenchon ont
perdu les classes populaires ils se sont
trouvés et ils se sont cherchés et
trouvés d'ailleurs un électorat de
substitution et l'électorat de
substitution ce sont les musulmans qui
ont voté à 69% pour Jean-Luc Mélenchon
c'est ce qui a fait ces gros scores dans
toutes les banlieues et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui il défilent contre
l'islamophobie et il m'accuse d'être de
pousser à la guerre etc etc moi je vais
vous dire il est moi aussi je déteste
qu'il est devenu parce que j'estime que
c'est lui qui a aujourd'hui forgé ce
peuple islamo gauchiste parce que qui a
voté pour lui les musulmans et les
gauchistes c'est pas grave il est
comment c'est pas
moi je connais des citoyens français qui
soit de n'importe quelle religion on est
d'accord donc on est français avant
évidemment mais sauf que tous les
sondages prouve et toutes les enquêtes
d'opinion pauvres que ils ont voté quel
que soit leur position politique ou sur
l'économie etc même si c'était pas
d'accord avec Mélenchon sur l'économie
pour des raisons justement
communautaires c'est ça qui est grave et
il a tout fait pour ça et il a réussi
donc si vous voulez moi j'estime que
c'est Mélenchon qui est dangereux pour
la France il est passé de l'amitié à
Zemmour à être
l'ennemi de la France et il s'en moque
il fait ça avec un cynisme absolu donc
si vous voulez oui moi aussi je pense je
déteste que dit Jean-Luc Mélenchon
aujourd'hui et je pense qu'il est
dangereux pour la France mais il s'en
moque vous comprenez
il est après moi le déluge il sait
exactement ce qu'il fait mais il se
moque complètement des conséquences à
long terme c'est ce que je répondais à
Madame tout à l'heure moi j'essaye de
voir les conséquences à long terme à 10
ans à 20 ans lui sans moque alors on a
des questions pour en quoi le rebondis
sur ce que vous venez je vous en prie en
quoi le vote musulman selon vous semble
être un problème peu importe que les
musulmans est votaient les Français
qui votent et s'expriment comme tant
d'autres tout à fait soit catholique
tout à fait bouddhiste tout ce que vous
faites ça devient
et tout à fait vous avez tout à fait
c'est pas un problème ça non non
attendez attendez c'est pas un problème
en soi évidemment c'est pas ce que j'ai
voulu dire ce que ça devient un problème
quand c'est toujours la même chose ça
devient un problème quand c'est un effet
de masse quand vous avez
70%, 75 % de gens de la même confession
qui votent pour un seul candidat ça
prouve qu'il y a un effet de et qui a un
effet si vous voulez communautaire quand
il y a un vote juif par exemple on parle
beaucoup de juif ou un vote
musulmanes madame
c'est les déclaration c'est déclaratifs
on le sait on le sait pour qui les Juifs
on le sait pour qui les catholiques
votent on sait pour qui les a il y a un
vote musulman en l'occurrence il y a eu
mais il y a pas toujours je dis pas
qu'il y a toujours là je dis qu'il a
tout fait pour et il y a eu Messi
d'ailleurs les enquêtes pardonnez-moi
monsieur Verdez les enquêtes d'opinion
le disent les gens l'expriment on a voté
pour lui car il luttait contre
l'islamophobie on a lutté pour lui on
peut pas pour les autres musulman de ne
pas voter pour Marine Le Pen au Congo
mais non mais attends forcement après il
reste tout Emmanuel Macron aujourd'hui
non mais c'est pas vrai c'est pas vrai
il y avait il y avait Anne Hidalgo il y
avait Yannick jadou il y avait Emmanuel
Macron est-ce que vous savez
on parle de ça sérieux là attendez
est-ce que vous avez que les Frères
musulmans les Frères musulmans là les
mosquées la Mosquée de Paris ont donné
des consignes pour qu'on vote Mélenchon
et au second tour on vote Macron
il y a aussi mais pense pas que ça
dérange les Français mais moi je suis
désolé
pour moi vous êtes sûrs
je marchais dans les rues et j'ai une
dame avec sa fille une dame de ma
génération avec sa fille qui devait
avoir 25-30 ans qui m'arrête et qui me
disent ce qu'on peut vous parler une
minute et tu rajoutes mais sur Madame et
voilà et la mère me dit je tiens à vous
dire madame monsieur je suis
musulmane ça fait 40 ans que je vis en
France vous avez tout à fait raison la
religion c'est dans le privé on n'a pas
à s'afficher on n'a pas avoir une fille
voilée dans la rue on n'a pas à montrer
sa religion dans la rue c'est vous qui
avez raison et on a voté pour vous et on
a appris des photos évidemment comme on
fait maintenant rituellement mais c'est
pour vous dire que il y a des musulmans
qui ont vécu la France des années 60-70
qui ont très bien connu cette France
authentiquement républicaine pour le
coup contrairement à ce qu'on dit
aujourd'hui c'est à dire la France de et
de la discrétion des religions moi je
vais vous dire je suis de confession
juive quand j'étais petit qu'on allait à
la synagogue on mettait la calotte sur
la tête on disait ça va vous amuser je
fais toujours cette réflexion là on
disait calotte en français et non pas
qui pas comme aujourd'hui vous voyez ce
que ça veut dire les mots tu n'es pas
important et ma mère dès qu'on sortait
de la synagogue elle m'attrapait comme
ça je la revois la peau elle m'attrapait
elle me disait tu m'enlèves ta calotte
tout de suite mais le monde a changé
mais il change en mal
la France c'est l'assimilation c'est le
fait que on ne doit pas montrer je vais
vous dire pourquoi pour ne pas choquer
les gens qui ne sont pas de cette année
pas dérangeante un voile n'est pas
dérangeant
vous dites les signes religieux dans
l'espace public ça ne devrait pas vous
déranger je ne l'était pas si vous
voulez le principe même de la de la
République et de la laïcité à la
française c'est que l'espace public est
absolument neutre et que les gens
peuvent s'y balader sans se poser la
question de savoir si Madame croit en
Dieu ou pas ou si vous vous êtes de
religion bouddhiste ou n'importe quoi
vous voyez c'est ça l'espace public à la
française c'est ça la République et donc
aujourd'hui on ne respecte plus à moi je
me bats pour ça je ne crois pas que ça
choque des musulmans qui ont compris ça
c'est tout donc quand je vous dis il y a
un problème de votre massif c'est c'est
le vote massif un problème important
c'est important quand c'est parce qu'il
coalise des gens sur leur religion et il
le fait exprès alors conviction alors
s'il vous plaît
une question c'est quoi le plus dur le
monde de la télévision le monde le monde
des médias ou le monde de la politique
en fait c'est ni l'un ni l'autre si vous
voulez
quand on est dans le monde de la
politique on a une élection et on a des
électeurs et donc il faut faire
attention à ce que pense tous les
électeurs c'est ça qui est le plus
difficile et on est sous la pression de
des adversaires c'est bien normal qui
qui attendent la moindre de de vos
besvues etc et des médias donc en fait
c'est beaucoup plus dur la vie de la
campagne une campagne présidentielle
c'est pas la vie politique en soi qui
est plus dure c'est la campagne
présidentielle je pense que la campagne
présidentielle d'ailleurs c'est c'est
unique avec le système américain
j'ai coutume de dire de Gaulle nous
alléguer un truc fou que lui d'ailleurs
il n'a jamais expérimenté puisque en 65
il s'est bien bien privé de faire
campagne et qu'il est sorti de sa boîte
au second tour mais voyez c'est quelque
chose de très dur une campagne il y a
pas plus de bâtard en politique
[Musique]
Éric Zemmour pour finir vous avez fait
quelle époque tiens samedi soir avec
faire un record d'audience donc ils vont
vous inviter
vous voyez ou pas et il y a une séquence
où ils font avec des visages en fait et
j'ai appris par une info quelqu'un qui
vous avez montré mais mon visage et que
ils l'ont coupé au montage c'est le seul
qu'ils ont coupé
je vais vous dire quelque chose mais non
est-ce que bah je vais le refaire vous
allez redire ce que vous avez je vais
mettre ma tête je vais mettre ma tête et
puis vous dites ce que vous avez dit
comme ça au moins je vais leur redonner
pour la semaine prochaine bah oui alors
je vais vous dire ce que je vous disais
parce que ça va vous faire plaisir je
vous connaissais assez peu non on se
connaissait même pas du tout
j'ai rencontré sur le plateau exactement
regardez peu cette émission je regarde
un peu la télévision en général
d'ailleurs voilà et euh j'ai trouvé et
c'est ça peut-être qu'il les a agacés je
pense que vous étiez vous vous étiez
bien débrouillé moi je suis journaliste
politique donc je me permets de juger en
professionnel je trouve que franchement
vous vous êtes très bien débrouillé je
le dis d'ailleurs partout je trouve que
vous animiez bien vos débat politique
que les questions étaient dignes d'un
journaliste politique et donc je vous
félicite pour ça peut-être que donc
je peux comprendre on peut le comprendre
merci
Eric Zemmour je n'ai pas dit mon dernier
mot